you you married no no okay I'm looking
to get about hey I'm about to be 55
about to be Double Nickel Double Nickel
yeah Double Nickel so what you think
about it though wait wait let's pretend
these cameras in here yeah it's me and
you Bob Chuck I've been talking like
they ain't here anyway
what you you your views on marriage what
do you think uh I would love to have
gotten married earlier in my career but
my career was the most important thing
so I was no good um I was a terrible
father I probably was a terrible brother
terrible son I definitely was a terrible
boyfriend because football was the most
important thing I was consumed with that
and I was consumed with that because I
wanted to get my grandmother my family
out of the conditions and I said if I
had kids I didn't want them to spend one
hour let alone a year like I spent so I
focused on that that was the only thing
that mattered right and I had a lot of
women say they could be okay with being
with number two to football but when it
came right down to it and they see how
devout I was in it they couldn't be
couldn't right and I said okay but now I
started to realize as I gotten older in
my life
everything that I've accumulated doesn't
mean anything if I don't have anybody to
share it with and it took me spending
time alone to realize that yes Shannon
you're great at what you do you you're
in the Hall of Fame you accomplished a
lot but at the end of the day who do you
share it with